[Music]  a recent survey has shown that up to  70 percent of our community is either  concerned  or very concerned about climate change  the impact of climate change will put  our core infrastructure  at risk it will require a rethink about  where and how we build  what goods we consume and overall how we  operate  the council is working on a climate  change response strategy  in support of new zealand and  waimakariri shift  to a low emission future by 2050.  [Music]  we're expecting more direction from the  government soon but it's clear that  investing  in a sustainable future now is going to  cost  a lot less than taking no action  visit waimakarari.govt.enz  forward slash let's talk to find out  more  [Music]